hey in this video I would talk about
genetic screen using fruit flies genetic
screen is just like fishing but instead
of fish here we have genes we fish for
genes now genetic screen in fruit flies
could be broadly divided into three
categories on is forward genetics screen
on is reverse genetic screen and one is
modified genetic screen the former
genetic screen and reverse genetic
screen are the most important ones while
modified genetic screen is a specific
specific type of genetic screen which is
important once we know something about
the signaling pathway and and we can
figure out this interactors in the
signaling pathway so first we talk about
for our genetic screen so for our
genetic screen is a way by in the in the
polar genetic screen what we do is we
know a particular phenotype or a process
and we do random mutations and see in
random mutant lines where the process is
perturbed or not then we go back and
check which gene is mutated so this is
the overview of our view of a forward
genetic screen in fruit flies what we do
we first induce random mutations and we
know what behavior or what type of
biological processes to look for so we
do a random mutation by either giving
x-rays which is pretty old fashioned
later and now people use EMS telemetry
himself on it which is the alkylating
agent causing changes in the DNA and
titrating the amount of the ethyl methyl
sulfonyl you can achieve mutations
almost in the oil all all of the
chromosomes so all of the chromosomes
has kind of equal probability of heating
but this particular mutagen so the
mutant fly let's say all the chromosomes
are hate and then we we we tune for we
look for the phenotypes that we are
expecting let's say we saw a biological
process is perturbed in the mutant that
means that that means in the mutant some
changes portrayal
that that's where you don't have the
biological process going on then we'll
go back and check with gene is mutated
so this is the outline of for our
genetic strain so for for our genetic
screen I have a detailed video if you
wish to look at it please click on the
link below now the other type of genetic
screen known as reverse genetic screen
where we know which gene we want to
mutate and wanted to see that if we
mutate this gene what is the effect of
its on on other on a particular
biological process or particular
development phase or a particular
phenotype let me give one example of a
reverse genetic screen one of the
popular way to do the first genetic
screen is to use RNA interference
technology now in drosophila using gal
for us system one can achieve RNA i
people can use people can use specific
tissue specific promoter to express gal
for and people have battery of RNA i
four different genes now using this
combination people can achieve RNA i
against specific genes now let's say
here we wanted to look at the dendritic
morphology of a particular neuron known
as neuron x and we we think that a to z
genes could be important for the
dendritic arborization of this neuron x
so what we are going to do in a
spaceship temporal manner we are going
to perturb the gene a to z individually
we are going to knock down a to z chain
so here in in this particular slide you
can see this neuron which is neuron x
let's say we made a gal for which is
specific to neuron x and here is our
experimental screen we have a battery of
RNA i lines against a to z genes and we
have a gal for which drives into that
specific neuron known as an x neuron now
we would create multiple crosses take
their f1 progenies and then we are going
to image their brain to check the
morphologic and we would score the
morphology let's say a hypothetical
result is like this few of the while
knocking few genes we have increased
arborization in contrast knocking some
gene give us decreased
arborisation suggesting this kind of
gene B could be a positive regulator
that's why when we knock it down we have
less arborization whereas gene a here
could be a negative regulator and that
is why when we knock down the negative
negative regulator we get more
arborization and we can call these kind
of simple simple features to see which
you knocking out with gene can affect a
process and thereby we can do reverse
genetic screen and there are many
successful reverse genetic screen which
has led to identification of many
important biological processes and
another type of genetic screen is known
as modified genetic screen and also
modified genetic screen has led to
identification of multiple pathways that
we now study in the textbooks so
modified genetic screen is also very
important and I will be talking about
modified genetic screen in a different
video
I hope this preliminary video helped you
if you like my video give it a quick
thumbs up please subscribe and like
thank